ANGLE.
TOMORROW, SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI
AND SENATE MINORITY LEADER
CHUCK SCHUMER RETURNED TO THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR A MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NOW, THIS TIME, IT'S ABOUT AN
INSTRUCTOR DEAL.
BUT IN A MOMENT, I'M GOING TO
TELL YOU WHAT THE SHOWDOWN IS
REALLY ALL ABOUT.
TODAY THE GUY WHO SPENT EIGHT
YEARS WORKING THERE, JOE BIDEN,
HE TRIED MIGHTILY TO CONVINCE
YOU THAT THIS TIME HE HAS ALL
THE ANSWERS.
BUT WHAT IS IN HIS PITCH IN THIS
PHENOMENAL TRUMP ECONOMY?
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO, I THINK
WE HAVE TO RETHINK HOW WE DEFINE
WHAT CONSTITUTES A SUCCESSFUL
ECONOMY.
>> Laura: HE CAN BARELY GET
THE WORDS OUT.
THAT'S CONVENIENT, RIGHT?
IF YOU CAN'T BEAT HIM, AS IN
TRUMP'S ECONOMIC NUMBERS, JUST
CHANGE THE WAY EVERYTHING IS
SQUARED BECAUSE BY TRADITIONAL
METRICS.
GDP, WAGE GROWTH, UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS AND THE STOCK MARKET,
TRUMP SHOULD BE A LOCK FOR 2020.
WHETHER YOU LIKE HIS TONE OR NOT
OR HIS TWEETS, THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEATEN ALMOST EVERY TARGET SET
BY THE SO-CALLED ECONOMIC
EXPERTS.
SPEAKING OF SO-CALLED EXPERTS,
NOBEL LAUREATE PAUL KRUGMAN, HE
PREDICTED AN ECONOMIC
APOCALYPSE, A GLOBAL RECESSION
AFTER TRUMP'S ELECTION.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT?
HERE'S TODAY'S HEADLINE.
SORRY, PAUL.
WHAT CAN WE EXPECT UNDER
PRESIDENT BIDEN?
WHAT WILL HE DELIVER?
SAY GOODBYE TO AMERICA FIRST
TRADE POLICIES THAT ARE WORKING.
BIDEN WAS A BIG ADVOCATE FOR THE
BOONDOGGLE KNOWN AS THE TRANSFER
TRAFFIC PARTNERSHIP.
OFFERING JOBS TO PLACES LIKE
MALAYSIA AND VIETNAM.
BYE-BYE TO TARIFFS.
BIDEN WOULD DIG ALL THE
PROTECTIONS FOR AMERICAN
WORKERS, DEALS LIKE THE USMCA.
IF YOU ARE ONE OF THE 450,000
AMERICANS WITH A NEW
MANUFACTURING JOB, YOUR FUTURE
WILL BE FAR FROM CERTAIN UNDER
BIDEN.
BUT REMEMBER, JOE PLEDGES TO
BRING YOU DIGNITY.
>> THE DIGNITY OF WORK IS MY
MISSION, WHICH IS ABOUT BEING
ABLE TO PROVIDE SECURITY AND
SHARE JOINT WITH YOUR FAMILY,
THE DEFINITION OF DIGNITY IS THE
PEOPLE SHOULD NEVER BE TREATED
AS A MEANS TO AN END.
BUT AN END AND THEMSELVES.
WHEN I THINK ABOUT WORK, I THINK
ABOUT DIGNITY.
I THINK ABOUT A LOT ABOUT MY
DAD, A PROUD GENTLE MAN.
MY DAD HAD AN INSPECTION.
HE SAID JOEY, OUR JOB IS ABOUT A
LOT MORE THAN PAYCHECK.
IT'S ABOUT YOUR DIGNITY.
IT'S ABOUT RESPECT.
>> Laura: OF COURSE HE FAILS
TO RESPECT THE TIGHT LABOR
MARKET THAT TRUMP'S POLICIES
HAVE HELPED CREATE.
WHAT DOES THAT DO?
THAT HELPS REGISTERING DIGNITY
BECAUSE WORKERS RAGES ARE
FINALLY GOING UP.
MORE MONEY IN YOUR POCKET, MORE
TIME TO SPEND WITH YOUR FAMILY.
NOW THAT ALL THOSE DIRE
PREDICTIONS, THEY ALL FAILED,
AND OTHER THINGS ARE GOING SO
WELL, BIDEN HAS BECOME HAS TO
THROW UP MAGIC REALITY OFFERING
DUST IN THE AIR TO CONVINCE YOUT
DUST IN THE AIR TO CONVINCE YOUA
DUST IN THE AIR TO CONVINCE YOUI
DUST IN THE AIR TO CONVINCE YOUS
DUST IN THE AIR TO CONVINCE YOUN
DUST IN THE AIR TO CONVINCE YOUT
DUST IN THE AIR TO CONVINCE YOUO
DUST IN THE AIR TO CONVINCE YOUE
OF THE BEST TIMES EVER TO BE AN
AMERICAN WHO IS WILLING TO WORK.
BY THE WAY, IT IS.
TRUMP OF COURSE HAS AN EASY
RESPONSE TO THAT.
>> REMEMBER, PRESIDENT OBAMA
SAID MANUFACTURING JOBS ARE
GONE.
YOU NEED A WAND, MAGIC WAND.
WE FOUND THE MAGIC WAND BECAUSE
THEY COMING AND THEY'RE COMING
FAST.
I LOVE THE FACT THAT WAGES ARE
RISING FAST AS FOR THE LOWEST
INCOME AMERICANS
PERCENTAGE-WISE.
WE ARE NOW THE NUMBER ONE
ECONOMY ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD
AND IT'S NOT EVEN CLOSE.
>> USA!
USA!
>> Laura: A LITTLE DIFFERENT
FROM THE BIDEN RALLY TODAY.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME TO DEAL WITH
CHUCK AND NANCY BECAUSE THEY ARE
BACK AT 1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE
TOMORROW WITH A FRAMEWORK FOR A
MASSIVE INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE.
REMEMBER LAST MONTH AT A
DEMOCRAT RETREAT, PELOSI FLOATED
UP PRICE TAG OF $2 TRILLION.
DEMOCRATS ALSO WANT TO EXPAND
THE DEFINITION OF WHAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IS BEYOND IN
OTHER WORDS FIXING BRIDGES,
ROADS, AIRPORTS, AND TO INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE ENHANCING BROADBAND,
WATER SYSTEMS, SCHOOLS, HOUSING.
WHY STOP THERE?
PREDICTABLY, DEMOCRATS WANT THE
COST TO BE BORNE BY PEOPLE,
MEANING YOU, BY DOING WHAT?
RAISING TAXES OF COURSE.
THAT'S A NONSTARTER FOR THIS
PRESIDENT BECAUSE HE BELIEVES A
TAX HIKE WILL SLOW THIS RED-HOT
ECONOMY, AND OF COURSE BETRAY
HIS CAMPAIGN PROMISES TO BE A
TAX CUTTER.
MY QUESTION IS THIS.
WILL THERE BE ANY KUMBAYA
MOMENTS?
IMAGINE IF THEY WERE SWAYING
BACK AND FORTH TOMORROW, GOT ON,
EITHER DURING OR AFTER THE
CONFAB.
HARD TO IMAGINE.
ANY COOPERATIVE SPIRIT GIVEN HOW
THEIR LAST MEET UP WENT DOWN.
>> IF WE DON'T HAVE BORDER
SECURITY, WERE NOT GOING TO KEEP
IT ALL.
>> WE WANT TO DO THE SAME THING
WE DID LAST YEAR THIS YEAR.
>> CHUCK, WE CAN BUILD A MUCH
BETTER --
>> LET'S DEBATE IN PRIVATE.
OKAY.
LET'S DEBATE IN PRIVATE.
>> WE CAME IN HERE IN GOOD FAITH
AND WE ARE ENTERING INTO THIS
KIND OF DISCUSSION IN THE PUBLIC
VIEW.
>> IT'S NOT BAD, NANCY.
IT'S CALLED TRANSPARENCY.
>> Laura: IS CALLED
TRANSPARENCY.
LET'S CLOSE THE DOORS AND KEEP
THE REPORTERS OUT.
MY FRIENDS, MAKE NO MISTAKE.
THIS WHOLE ROUTINE TOMORROW IS
AS MUCH ABOUT SETTING THE
NARRATIVE FOR 2020 AS IT IS
ABOUT GETTING SOMETHING DONE
THAT IS TRADITIONALLY A
BIPARTISAN EFFORT,
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IF INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING TEN
PAY FOR ITSELF BY STIMULATING
THE ECONOMY, CREATING ITS OWN
REVENUE STREAM, I GUESS YOU
CAN MAKE THE ARGUMENT FOR IT.
BUT IF NOT, WE SHOULDN'T DO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING, AT
LEAST NOT RIGHT NOW.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ARE
ADDICTED TO SPENDING YOUR MONEY
ALBEIT THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES.
REPUBLICANS, REMEMBER, WERE
ITCHING TO BUST THOSE OBAMA ERA
SPENDING CAPS TO JACK UP
MILITARY SPENDING.
THEY THOUGHT IT WAS JUSTIFIED.
DEMOCRATS, WELL THEY ARE
PLANNING ON SPENDING MONEY WE
DON'T HAVE ON THINGS LIKE GREEN
ENERGY, FREE COLLEGE HOWEVER YOU
PRESCHOOL, FOR EVERYTHING.
>> WE ARE ANNOUNCING THE MOST
AMBITIOUS, CLIMATE PLAN.
>> WE ARE GOING TO DELIVER A
MEDICARE FOR ALL SINGLE-PAYER
SYSTEM.
>> MAKE COLLEGE UNIVERSALLY
AVAILABLE WITH FREE TUITION AND
FEES.
>> WE WILL GUARANTEE THAT RIGHT
WITH UNIVERSAL PRE-K AND DEBT
FREE COLLEGE.
>> Laura: NO END TO THE
SPENDING BUT THIS MY FRIENDS IS
A NATIONAL DEBT CLOCK.
AND IT'S OBSCENE.
THAT WE ARE DOING THIS TO FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
TALKING ABOUT ENTITLEMENTS,
CHANGING THEM, REFORMING THEM
AND NO ONE EVER DOES THEM
ANYTHING ABOUT THEM.
AXIOS REPORTS CHUCK AND NANCY
ARE CAREFULLY PREPARING FOR THIS
MEETING TOMORROW WITH THE
PRESIDENT BUT THEY WANT TO DO IT
IN ORDER TO GAIN MAXIMUM
POLITICAL BENEFIT.
THEIR TRUE AIM IS TO SET UP
WHOMEVER THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE
USED AS THE DEFENDER OF THE
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN AGAINST
THE RICH EXECUTIVES.
CONSIDERING BIDEN'S PERFORMANCE
TODAY, HE NEEDS ALL THE HELP HE
CAN GET.
>> IT'S NOT JUST PEOPLE WHO
4-YOUR COLLEGE DEGREES BUT THOSE
WHO COMPETE FOR JOB TRAINING